the three of us are sitting with the
unfolding events of the times and
thinking about the great arc of
transformation that life imposes upon us
young thought greatly about his own
process as well as the process of the
culture and if he were here today he
might say that we are all participating
in a collective Negredo that something
is emerging that is unexpected that we
weren't prepared for that demands an
accommodation and that causes the death
of all kinds of illusions both
collectively and individually and how do
we sit in that well maybe it seems like
the first place to start is to just
start with that term and define it a
little bit Negredo is a term that comes
from alchemy which was kind of a
medieval young belief sort of a
spiritual practice that that later
became chemistry actually but Jung was
fascinated by alchemy because the
incredibly figurative language these
colorful metaphors that the alchemists
wrote about us they worked with
materials he felt were metaphors for
psycho spiritual transformation
so the Negredo was often referred to as
a black blacker than black it sounds so
mystical the black blacker than black of
the the darkness and that place also
where there there's no light but it's
also associated with the incubation
process likened to pregnancy that takes
place unseen within in a blackness or a
seed beginning to germinate in the
blackness of soil so it's associated
with a kind of at least an opportunity
for a beginning I don't know
that it's restricted to that but it
often appears at the beginning of
psychological work and I think we see
that a lot of people come in because
they're in the life crisis under grado
what that brings to mine Jimmy Deb is
that there are times in our lives where
we begin to get the sense that something
very very important is about to take
place
but it hasn't landed yet and there's a
kind of pressure that begins to thrum in
the personality sometimes even in the
body in the emotions which gives us a
kind of anxious sense of something
bigger than us that's arriving are we in
a kind of place like that right now
collectively mm-hmm of that we are in a
kind of darkness we're isolated secluded
hopefully many of us anyway in our homes
and yet there is that sense of anxiety
and what next and where are we going
yeah and you know I think it's important
to not wander too far away from the fact
that the Negredo is associated with the
suffering you know young at one point
talks about it being analogous to this
mystical idea of the dark night of the
soul I mean it may be where something
new is germinating but boy it sure does
not feel like that
it more feels like the the the death and
the rotting away of everything that we
previously clung to and that's why it's
also associated with the alchemical
operations of mortification and
putrefactive I think that there are
subcategories around the Negredo which
by the way is is just a Latin word for
black and you know when we look at a
piece of fruit or any kind of natural
process a leaf falls from a tree and it
loses its
greenness and eventually rots down into
the blackness of soil that it it
suggests that there's a kind of natural
process that's occurring but there are
subcategories
so the Negredo the mortification and the
putrefactive so this idea of something
turning black something beginning to die
and then something beginning to rot but
they're all in this category of
saturnine decay but I think the Negredo
is thought of as the initial part of
that which for Jungian work can be the
confrontation with the shadow absolutely
and there's so much about that that it's
a subjectively experienced process
brought about by the subjects painful
growing awareness of his shadow aspects
and it does I think take us by surprise
just as this pandemic has taken us by
surprise where did this come from how
panic came out of nowhere it seems in
its suddenness and it's all-encompassing
quality on the collective front and
individually it takes us over as well
yeah there there is a sense of no stable
ground it isn't there and I think that
that there's a way that when something
so big is going on in the collective
right now as with the pandemic you know
just like I imagine you know a world war
would feel this way - it just feels like
you know everything is suddenly tossed
up in the air there's no we have no
stable footing we don't know what's
going to happen and it brings about this
well it can lend itself to a
reorganization of the personality where
everything kind of comes into question
but